[Music]
yeah it's a gas mkbhd here and yeah some
secrets are harder to keep than others
but this is a good one so for the past
two weeks I've been using the new Mac
Pro which means every video you've seen
since then since the MacBook Pro review
has been edited on the Mac Pro thank you
very much for watching catch you later
base but also low-key though you guys
didn't know about this but that's
another video so yeah this is something
I've been personally waiting for for the
better part of the last six years or so
since the 2013 trashcan Mac Pro came out
and in tech years that's like forever so
while it's a bit early to do a full
review I figure I might as well give you
my second impressions or my impressions
from using it daily for the past two
weeks
[Music]
[Music]
so the box is clearly really interesting
there's some velcro on each side you get
past that it's really sturdy it does
kind of remind me of the original cheese
grater Mac Pro box but a little nicer on
one side got your magic keyboard in its
own box and on the other side you have a
Magic Mouse a magic trackpad and a
braided black lightning cable and I'll
get back to those in a minute then the
last step to getting it out the box is
gripping it by those top handles and
this thing is pretty heavy it's solid
metal so I guess I shouldn't be
surprised but it is very dense and then
in the Box we just took it out of on the
bottom you have your designed by Apple
in California pamphlet and underneath
that is another braided cable this one's
the power cable and it's definitely
sturdy and high-quality for that 1400
watt power supply and as a matter of
fact in with the rest of the Mac Pro
paperwork you do in fact get yes to not
one but two gigantic black Apple
stickers these are got to be the biggest
Apple stickers I've ever seen maybe you
can put them on your car or something
so yeah new Mac Pro and as you can see
two new protists play XD ours on their
nifty thousand dollar stands that I've
been using for the past two weeks we saw
this already at WWDC and I gave my first
impressions there I'll link it below if
you want to rewind that a bit but this
is like a second impressions so here's
the specs of this machine that I've been
using it's got a maxed out 28 core Intel
Xeon w CPU 384 gigs of 29 33 megahertz
RAM and two of the AMD radeon vega pro 2
MPX modules with 32 gigs of VRAM on each
card and then there's four terabytes of
storage and it does have the afterburner
card so not maxed out but as you can
tell very nicely equipped I probably
will end up getting something around
this same spec and the 8 terabytes of
SSD storage since that's just a massive
amount of room and probably some more
RAM and actually any about this Mac tool
on the Mac Pro gives you this visual now
of not only your storage but your DIMM
slots of how you're using the 6 channel
RAM you can see this one's using half of
the slots right now and the PCI slots so
you can see this top one is Apple's
built-in card the afterburner card is
below it and then the 2 MPX modules
which are double height with the Radeon
Pro cards below those and it even shows
which unpopulated PCI slots is blocking
so to share a few things we'll notice
right off the bat first of all the
accessories that comes with the mouse
the keyboard the Magic Trackpad
are all black so on my desk for a while
I'd had the Space Gray keyboard and
trackpad that came with the iMac pro now
you have a black trackpad with a silver
base and black bottom and a magic
keyboard that's black keys with silver
base and even the Magic Mouse that it
comes with goes from a Space Gray top
and bottom two silver bottom with a
gloss black top now I don't know how
many people buying a Mac Pro
are sticking with the magic keyboard and
Magic Mouse but hey it's a nice touch
and then the thing is just I know it's
off camera because it's under my desk
right now but it is built really well
and of course the cheese grater look we
all refer to it as is very distinctive
there's like little spheres in the front
with circular cutouts on the edges of
those spheres hopefully that explains it
but all around
tight tolerances not really any
unnecessary gaps anywhere it's clean
there's also an option to get it on
wheels in the Apple store but as you can
see this one that doesn't have the
wheels just got metal flat feet but I
think I might actually want to get the
wheels possibly and then the ports so
okay the main accessible ones that are
on the top front are just your two
Thunderbolt ports which are next to the
power button and the little white
glowing power indicator that's pretty
basic then at the back you get by
default to full-size and then two more
Thunderbolt ports and a headphone jack
and then each GPU module is given you an
HDMI and for more Thunderbolt and then
all the way at the bottom next to power
is dual ten gigabit ethernet ports nice
and that's not a sarcastic nice either
that's like actually really useful for
me for me that's the superfast internet
we can go wired in and the jellyfish
drives that we headed off but yeah only
two full-sized USB ports I kind of would
have liked to have seen a little bit
more than that many many legacy
peripherals at this point that a lot of
mac pro users continue to use aren't
updated to USB type-c yet so for me I
instantly populated those that was the
the receiver for my mouse and the SD
card reader so already that's full there
was also an internal USB a port but I
found that when I put the mouse receiver
inside it tends to start glitching and
sort of get worst reception so I never
really put that inside so yeah not ideal
I wish there were like two more USB a
ports on the back there maybe I should
just get another USB C card reader
because at this point this is my only
USB type-c card reader and I kind of
hate that anyway okay opening up the Mac
Pro is really as simple as it looks
there are no thumb screws like normal
cases it's just a huge twist latch at
the top rotate it half way and the
entire shell slides off cleanly exposing
the insides simple as that so that's
where on one side you can see the
motherboard the top containers on the
right side here hold the RAM and then if
you flip it around you can see there's
your PCI slots the big MPX modules with
the graphics cards at the bottom and on
the long afterburner card right above
them and a CPU and the heatsink for it
are up at the top and you can also see
that internal full-sized USB a port
right above Apple's built-in card so I
have two main takes that I've noticed
from using this computer for the past
two
one it's really quiet and two it's
really fast the quietness is pretty
objective I mean you can put it it's
four feet from the mic right now and you
can't really hear it but in a normal
office environment it's not the loudest
thing in any room hard drives are louder
than it any fans anything else in the
area is louder it's very quiet I don't
keep it on my desk because there's not
enough room with the speakers but I
could and I'd be fine really the main
reason it's so quiet is because they've
minimized fans there's really just in
this Mac Pro one fan for the power
supply on one side and then three large
fans at the front just blowing air
through all the time so there's no
dedicated water cooling pump or CPU
cooler fan or GPU fans or anything
separate like that everything inside is
passively cooled and just depends on the
airflow coming through from the three
big fans at the front that's what makes
that cheesegrater hole design so
important it's really an airflow design
and that's also something to keep an eye
on down the road and it's also
potentially concerned as Linus mentioned
in his first impressions video of dust
getting in because there is no obvious
air filter in front of or behind any of
these fans I like that it doesn't intake
air from the bottom that means I can put
it on any carpeted surface and be fine
but we have to keep an eye on dust that
might eventually make its way into the
Machine and affect thermals we'll see
but also yeah it's really fast as you
would expect from something with 28
cores and 384 gigs of RAM here's the
geek bench score you know it's great
it's the highest I've ever seen on any
computer love that I also did a black
magic disk speed test and as you'd
expect from the internal SSD three
gigabytes per second again hilariously
fast but if I can just hold off on
benchmarks for a minute
the main place I'm noticing the
difference is the main place where my
workflow is heavy the main reason I
wanted a Mac Pro and that's in video
editing so for me that's Final Cut Pro
so if you remember the the rendering
speed test I did in the MacBook Pro
review I've rendered out this clip from
red raw and I had my times for the
MacBook Pro and the iMac Pro well I
couldn't tell you guys in that video but
I also tested the Mac Pro on that same
test so the render speeds for this
MacBook Pro were about 20 minutes
they're under speed for the iMac Pro
brought it all the way down to around 11
minutes and
MacPro did that same test and exported
it in four minutes and 20 seconds Wow
just for some reference for some people
who might not appreciate that that's
exporting that's transcoding an 8k red
code clip I typically shooting around an
8 to 1 compression ratio as I did with
the test clip 2 to 1 aspect ratio no
background rendering and just went
straight through in faster than real
time so it was a 5 minute clip on the
timeline exported the whole thing in
less time than it would take to just
watch that clip so yeah that's pretty
great I will get much more into detail
in performance and how well it does in
the full review which will be coming
later and if you guys have more
suggestions for different ways that you
want me to test it that's welcome in the
comments section below specific
workflows and things like that but I've
been very happy with the performance and
none of this has even been taking
advantage of the afterburner card yet
because that's optimized for pro res
footage and playback I've been shooting
in our 3d read raw but I will of course
give this shot with pro res footage for
the full review as well that's what it's
made to streamline but in the meantime I
am super pumped about Mac Pro my two
weeks with it have been relatively
pain-free just setting everything up
again I'm interested in what you want to
see in the for review but my take is
this is one of those tools that I'm just
excited about as a creator I feel like
at this point you know 2019 2020 it
takes a lot to get me inspired as a
creator because the tools I have in my
disposal are so unlimited like there's
no way I can take this camera to its
full potential but I was pretty
consistently pushing the iMac pro the
fastest machine that runs Final Cut Pro
to its full potential so it's not like
magic it's not like having this Mac Pro
is going to make my videos better or
make anyone's videos better but it's
just it's it's sort of a Headroom
unlocker essentially it pulls down the
barrier for what I'm willing to try as a
creator because of power or speed or
time and I think for a lot of other
workflows this represents the same thing
so yeah thank you Apple for making this
and thank you for watching this second
prescience video definitely be sure to
get subscribed to see the full review
when it comes out if you haven't already
and uh looking forward to seeing your
comments chat with you gather the next
one
base